let's go next to Dylan from Georgia
Dylan from Georgia welcome to the
program what's on your mind today
Dylan from Georgia you were on but
you've got to select the correct audio
device
hey David can you hear me yeah now I can
cool last time I was on we had a I
sounded like a robot was speaking I
don't know if you remember that well
that happens with a lot of callers I
have to admit
yeah well I've been a member for a while
and I'm it's great to talk to you
um I just had uh kind of two questions
um the first one was
I don't know how much research you've
done into it but what are your thoughts
on the willow project being approved in
Alaska and um kind of how does that make
you feel with the contrast of all of Joe
Biden's promises about you know trying
to combat the climate crisis and more
electric cars and tax incentives for
electric when I read that I think the
willow project would produce the
equivalent of 2 million gas powered cars
yeah so I don't know how much you've
read about that so here I have a bunch
of Articles bookmarked to read and the
insanity on Twitter this week made it so
I didn't get to from the little I've
read so far I'm very concerned about it
I want to learn more and maybe next week
I'll do like more of a deep dive segment
on it but I'm certainly I'm certainly
quite concerned about it from what I'm
from the little I've read so far
yeah yeah I've it it concerned me a lot
too
um and I you know I I've been reading a
lot of I don't know if you know who Nate
Higgins is but he has a smaller youth
smaller YouTube channel about um what he
calls I guess the meta crisis which is
just this feeling that everybody has
that
something is wrong and we don't quite
know how to address it he does a good
job of kind of consolidating that but he
just mostly talks about the climate
stuff in the sense that
you know we need a cultural change not
necessarily making things more efficient
and even the drive to try to make things
efficient as quickly as we would need to
right in order to combat this stuff is
almost counterproductive because of the
things that we would use to construct
all of these green technologies rely on
fossil fuels and also you know it's just
it's a cultural shift that we have to
make and you know I guess it starts at
the individual level you know I try to
cycle but that's that's pretty much all
I can do at this point is just cut back
as best I can and I'm sure you're like
you're not you're not flushing your
toilet 10 to 15 times which I'm sure
helps
you know I'm I'm trying you know I'm at
eight right now I'm really trying to
take it down to five that would be good
but uh yeah if we could only flush only
five times it'd be better yeah I just
made a note about Nate Higgins the
content seems interesting I'm gonna
check it out
yeah yeah definitely yeah thanks David
all right Dylan from Georgia great to
hear from you